ha pasado un año son múltiples las
crisis que deja este conflicto pero en
Qué ámbitos se puede hablar puntualmente
de crisis
las crisis variadas empiezan primero
desde el hecho que hay una guerra y en
Europa una guerra significa un cambio
total de la vida normal que se había
establecido a partir de fenómenos de
guerra en el siglo 20 entonces Esto no
es una vida ordinaria donde sabemos que
hay tanques hay gente que sufre hay
refugiados hay asuntos que se deben
resolver militarmente después pensemos
en las sanciones una extensión es que se
hacen a Rusia pero unas sanciones que
perjudican a Europa unos cambios
inflaciones preguntes hay gas Bueno pero
en qué precios Qué vamos a hacer después
todo lo diplomático que se destruyendo
es en un nivel en cual Europa como Unión
Europea pero también y como todo un
continente con casi 50 países debe
responder para que se puede establecer
la paz y pensemos en un asunto como de
vida cotidiana porque los rusos son
nuestros vecinos son gente que están
presentes hay gente que habla ruso que
tiene su simpatía con Rusia o que son
rusos y una rusofobia que se puso en
Europa vamos a decir que esto hace
recordar siglo 20 y la gran pregunta es
cuando se acabe esta guerra para volver
a vivir como vecinos
que vamos a repasar a lo largo de este
especial son por ejemplo es la crisis
humanitaria millones de personas han
tenido que salir de sus países y
refugiarse en naciones vecinas en
Polonia y Alemania por ejemplo conocemos
cuál es la situación de personas en
vulnerabilidad que tienen que se
encuentran esos territorios sí conocemos
porque la Unión Europea ha ayudado a
este movimiento de personas como
refugiados y vamos a decir que algunas
personas jóvenes
están dentro de unas oportunidades de
estar en la Unión Europea pero otras
personas que están en una edad de 50 60
años y ellos se salieron y no querían
abandonar sus casas y se devolvieron
para estar con sus casas porque su
tierra y su casa después pensemos en
gente que estaba bajo el fuego y bajo
todo este desastre que trae la guerra y
quedaron sin gases o gente que tenía que
decidirse imagínense un matrimonio entre
una persona ucraniana y un Ruso y los
niños se sienten que pertenecen a a su
país pero el padre dice yo estoy con
Rusia y la mamá es ucraniana tenían que
tomar decisiones muy difíciles pero
vamos a decirlo nadie ha olvidado
Ucrania y posiblemente muchos van a
regresar